if you love all the birds and trees all
the fishes in the Seas if you think
videos of pets is as good as it gets
this segment this review we hope your
furry dreams come true it's time to
celebrate bricks and I'm a friends
yes
it's Greg's animal friends a brand new
segment where each guest shares a video
of an amazing creature of course it
could be misbehaving doing something
cute the Only Rule the videos can't be
crappy well unless they're crapping
then I love them Todd do you have one
I've got a cow oh cow really and I and
is it with a duck no okay a cow by
itself and I feel that the article that
described what happened with this cow
defamed said cow really can we roll the
cow oh this is in uh cuts down cuts down
cuts down yeah so here's what happened
the Kutztown University described that
cow as aggressive no does that look like
an aggressive cow to you no he's
prancing the best line from the article
though I had to read this multiple times
because we're all reading from our
papers today officials reported the cow
appeared unfamiliar with the area and
disoriented heading nowhere in
particular are those things that
actually need to be said in this article
were you expecting the cow to have like
a specific destination you know cuts
down Pennsylvania which is kind of an
Eastern PA uh it has some great
antiquing so there might have been maybe
the cow was looking for something
something maybe from like an Amish
period sure uh and he was heading to
Lancaster where they have a little great
deals on all sorts of furniture and I
would suggest going there or possibly
going to Reading Pennsylvania on
September 16th where I'll be appearing
nice that was beautiful that was
impressive Kat um what do you have to
share mine is the duck and the cow oh
yours is duck in the cow sorry to
disappoint you but I think this is okay
well there's a huge opportunity with
this video for the ladies and I'll
explain in a minute so there's a cow and
a duck milkshake is the duck and
dumplings the cow and they love each
other so much look at this he won't even
go swimming without the cow the duck's
like I gotta make sure the cow is good
to go swimming and then okay now I can
go swimming ladies I want you to turn to
your husband and ask him why he doesn't
love you that way yeah
that is true does he wait for you to go
swimming or just go take this angle if I
were a cow would you still love me
would you wait for me to swim or would
you perhaps not take me swimming at all
really makes you think it really does
make you think I think you took what
would be a normal banal story and you
turned it into maybe a question about
life in general I did yeah I think we
learned a little bit about ourselves in
the world
it just brings me a little hope to think
that there might be some couple out
there in America screaming at each other
right now
did anyone else think about drowning
somebody
all right Governor what you got
I've got my two dogs
from Rio you know
you don't light in my life now that both
of my kids are out of the house but they
love to play monster under the blanket
they each are the monster and they don't
realize it's the other one fighting back
and so they're a lot of fun and I think
there there's another video of Bentley
chasing a crab but they're I mean that's
those are my two little ones you know I
used to play monster under a blanket
stop stop it I love that we made eye
contact I knew that was coming yeah you
guys always find each other in the room
summer camp 1993. okay yeah I was in my
30s okay I had pictures of my daughters
coming up here
oh you do yeah maybe not well
what if this was a wholesome story I'm
telling you the only thing wholesome
about is the creepiness yeah
his eyes lit up
really went to save the show at all
costs
what you got
uh I don't know because I was on a plane
sending this stuff but recently a camera
crew came to my house because they
wanted to film my little animal zoo so
my daughters were breaking out some of
their Critters and that's my daughter
Georgie and she's holding uh her giant
ball python which is about to lay eggs
and so the camera crew came to interview
me but I didn't really talk to him that
much because my daughters took them on a
fantastic Journey all through uh the
back of my pool house and got all the
snakes out and a bunch of other stuff
and scared the holy living hell out of
the cameraman
with uh with a you got lizards too don't
you yeah there's like uh oh there's
she's that's her iguana and he lets her
kiss her on him on the nose when he
feeds her and stuff so they were just
having a blast doing all kinds of stuff
that they're not allowed to do when I'm
there so but it was a fun day but yeah I
have a small a small zoo we got about
over probably 75 different reptiles and
snakes wow isn't that amazing yep yeah
and I make my kids work it for free yes
all right we got to move on that was fun
that was our inaugural Greg's animal
friends with the best song ever hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else